- Alright, so a family's
at the hospital.
Sitting around a deathbed of
their granddad.
It's real sad, 'cause
their granddad is only 38.
He had an asthma attack
doing the Whip and Nae Nae
with these two bitches
he met on Tinder.
One of them was pregnant,
which we don't even know how
'cause he ain't even hit yet.
Anyway, everybody's sad,
sayin' their last goodbyes.
Aunt Betty comes up to try
to do her last goodbye.
She got some big ass titties,
little bitty tank top,
some "Baywatch" shit,
'cause it get hot in Flint.
Next thing you know, she
leans over to kiss him
on the forehead, saying goodbye,
but the titty graze his
lip. Boop! Titty taste good.
He's like, "God damn, what's
that? Pear lotion? Lotion?
Pear flavored lotion?"
Next thing you know, his
dick started risin' up,
he gettin' an erection
underneath the sheets.
Then he flatline.
Dooooooooooooo.
It wasn't two beeps. I
just can't do a whole flat.
Next thing you know,
the chyron pops up.
Viagra. Granddaddy dead,
but that dick ain't.